vive l'été à guyancourt la ville
organise l'événement pour la deuxième
année consécutive une manifestation
estivale proposant du sport du cinéma en
plein air des spectacles et des
animations dont les quartiers objectif
offrir un bol d'air frais aux habitants
en cette période compliquée le maire de
guyancourt à a souhaité à l issue du
premier confinement voilà qu'on offre un
bol d'air un peu de un peu de joie aux
habitantes et aux habitants voilà au
sortir d'une période qui a été difficile
pour tout le monde et puis aussi où
beaucoup de personnes n'ont pas pu
partir en vacances une programmation co
construite avec les différents
équipements de la ville à la fiche des
spectacles gratuits en plein air et aux
styles variés
on présentera par exemple de 20 21 22 23
juillet monsieur blanchette et le loup
qui est une adaptation de la chèvre de
monsieur seguin en théâtre qui se jouera
dont quatre soirs différents dans quatre
quartiers différents de la ville
et puis on peut aussi citer le 24
juillet au jardin paul et virginie un
concert de djazia satour voilà qui sera
sans doute un très très beau moment
musical
[Applaudissements]
mandel le temps fort de cette deuxième
édition aura lieu les 17 et 18 juillet
pour l'occasion le jardin de l'ermitage
ouvrira exceptionnellement ses portes au
public
il accueillera cinq à six spectacles par
jour on aura un carrousel forains on
aura du cirque on aura des musiques
actuelles on aura du compte de la
musique classique énormément de choses
et également des stands tenus par les
associations dans une logique de
développement durable
le dernier concert aura lieu le 28 août
l'ensemble national de reggae déambulera
dans le jardin paul et virginie au
quartier du pont du rotois
[Musique]